Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Reading Your Comments!
♪Sheebidee-bapbee-dee-boobah♪
Whoa, that's wrong, okay
"Mark, tell Amy you're pregananant."
Okay... Alright then
Amy: She got the hiccups.
*rumbling in the background*
*pants* Amy
I'm pregananant.
*laughs*
"I LUBZ POTTATO?!?! DEW YEW?!?"
I do love potato
*kiss*
ugh, dirt-
"Is the third pole dancing video coming out anytime?"
"Stares intently"
*cliché horror music*
Yeah, I've been-
I've been promising the third pole dancing video
for a long time now
And you know what?-
I'm just gonna say
after the tour, we're definitely gonna do that
and I'm not saying like
'after the tour for a nebulous amount of time',
We're going to schedule it
so that as soon as we come back from tour,
we're going to make another pole dancing video,
how 'bout that?
and it'll be super cool
Or not!
"Mark, sing to a potato to unlock Chica's ancient powers!"
*Phantom of The Gonads*
"Dear Mark, I have a question for you
How would you pronounce: Drakensberg, KwaZulu-Natal?"
I don't know..
Maybe the internet knows?..
"penis."
[pffftt]
"draco malfroy quazoodle..
nazal."
No.
"girra- Please delete the CrankGamePlays chan-"
*giggles*
"drakunsbourg?..
dragonsbourg?
I love dragons!"
"I was just like, crying
'cause I was thinking of something but
I'm doing this because I love you Mark
And I would do anything for you
*sniff*
So, drakunsbourg, jakunsbourg..
.. I don't know *heh*
screw it.
I just love you so much Mark
And I can't wait to see you at the Houston tour soon
Love you *mwah*"
*giggles* That's so nice
"drakensberg.. kwaZuulu-naTall?"
Close?..
"Doesn't seem that hard, I'm probably wrong-
UHHHUHHUHH-"
*laughs*
"Draxun- uh..
draksun fuCKYOU."
Ooh! My feelings!!
"Drakenberg, KazooLu-NeTowel."
*Laughs*
I love how you got the whole
the whole family involved
Okay, but I think the answer to that question is
'No one knows.'
It's a mystery forever
"Hey Mark! I'm graduating high school soon!
Do you have any advice for me?
(If you actually see this i'm a huge fan!
I've been watching for about three years!)"
Well, thank you so much for watching
and if I have any advice to give
-- even though my yonder years of high school
seemed so long ago now --
but if I have any advice to give
it's 'Never stop trying new things.'
like, no matter what you're doing
even if you're going to college
or if you're going straight into work
or whatever you're doing
the world is open to you
but it won't be handed to you.
High school is structured
in the way that you do exactly what you're told
and then you get a piece of paper
that says 'You're ready for the world.'
uh-
But what it doesn't teach you is
that the world is what you make of it
like, even if you're going into college,
Try hobbies.
Join clubs.
Meet people.
Meeting people is probably the best skill
that you could possibly ever learn
and you gotta do it with baby steps
by taking it very slow.
And I went to college after high school,
I didn't take those steps
to go out and push my comfort zone out.
It wasn't until after college
that I really started to find who I was
when I started doing
YouTube.
Becauce I continually tried to do new things.
So just keep that spirit and you'll be fine-
"You should let Amy do your makeup."
Okay
M: Hi! Welcome to the 'Boyfriend Makeup Tag'!
M: uh, I hate tha-
A: Ka-chow
M: That sounds- That's terrif-
A: Boyfriend does my makeup.
M: Girlfriend does my makeup.
A: Boyfriend does my makeup
*laughs*
M: Hi. Welcome to-
A: Wait who says the -
*more laughing*
M: Hey.. It's makeup time
M: So just make it as good as you can
A: Well..
M: and hope for the best..
A: People are going to get mad at me if I don't do it right
M: Feels like i'm being massaged..
M: by a thousand hamsters..
A: Oh my god, hold on..
A: I'm gonna wipe it off on this potato
M: You could just use a towel *laughs*
M: Go for it.
M: make the potato beautiful too
M: Potatoes, they have a million uses!
M: Who knew?!
M: Is this going to give me the subscribers
M: I've always asked for?
*laughs*
A: Hold on..
M: Yeah? Is it good?
A: It's good.
M: It's good, right?
A: Okay, so eyeliner..
M: You wouldn't lie to me
M: You're laughing at me-
A: Oh no- Nonono!
A: No, close it!
A: Oh nooooo
M: Oh nooo, whut 'appened?
A: You goofed a little
M: How did I goof it?
A: Where did I put the makeup remover?..
M: I was just trying to livee
A: Okay, ya know what? It's-
M: It's good?
A: What's done is done.
M: What's done is done, which means it's good?
M: There you go!
I assume I'm beautiful
Ooh...
*laughs* that's a look
This is the first time i'm seeing myself.
Yeah, that's a thing-
"Mark, I sexually identify as an undercooked potato.."
Me too [crunch]
Am I cool yet?
"Do a 'Try Not To Cry' Challenge.
We need to see you cry more often."
Why do you need that?!
I mean, I can to a 'Try Not To Smile'
which almost made me cry anyway
but oh my god-
"Mark did you ever had a hard time in life as a kid
I'm 10, and been having hard times since 5."
Yes, and it's a little bit odd
for me to be serious while wearing this makeup
but, uhh yeah, you know
uh
Growing up as a kid, I didn't have the worst childhood
umm
But you know, my parents got divorced
and then we didn't have a lot of money
but
I never really thought of it as
like, the worst childhood that I could possibly imagine
because I got to spend so much time with my dad
And if he could see me now!
*laughs* I bet he'd be so proud of me right now!
"Hi!! I hope you don't die horribly in your sleep
at exactly 3:41am."
Thank you...
Me neither...
That'd be bad...
"I think the best quote I've ever heard you say is
'I destroyed Detroit for a piece of cake.'"
Yeah, it's funny about that
We're doing a tour now
and we're going to have a show in Detroit
and somehow..
They expect me to apologize?
No dammit! I'm not gonna apologize!
I got cake out of the deal..
"Ur a scrub"
Thanks.
"Hey Mark, why not pick up Mario Maker again?
I mean, if you REALLY want to frustrate yourself."
Y'know, there'a a common misconception here
I don't wanna frustrate myself
It just happens that way
And i'm so competitive when I playing it
that I don't want to lose to the game.
"Have you found out something about yourself,
while becoming more and more popular in the last few years
because everyone views such a lot of your life,
that you don't like about yourself,
or do like about yourself, you didn't notice before?"
That's actually a really interesting question,
Because, yeah
I've discovered a lot of who I am
in the 5 years that I've been doing YouTube.
Like, I've discovered, like
what I want and what I want to accomplish
and what motivates me
and- and it's hard to nail down just one thing
but I think the most important thing
that I learned once I started doing this
and, I guess you could attribute to getting more popular
but what I- what I realized is that
I can actually take control of my life
I- I can, I- I can do what I want to do
and I can do it the way that I want to do it
so long as I put my mind to it
and it's not even like a- a motivational thing
where you're like: "You can achieve any thing!
You can be an astronaut if you want to-
I wish-"
But,
I- It's more of a- a- a thing where
what's in my life is under my control
and I have the choice.
I literally have the choice to.. Influence my own life
And in doing so, that can ripple across to everyone I meet
And that's a very powerful thing
and it's a very powerful thing to learn and understand
and I think that it's very cool..
That we all have the same ability to do that,
we all can change the course of our life
just by making one decision
and in doing so, that can ripple across the entire world.
and that is.. Really, really cool to hear
and really cool to learn.
-Hard to get serious when I'm wearing makeup like this
but you know, I try.
So anyways that is all the time that I got for
Reading Your Comments
Thank you everybody so much for your comments.
I did pull from other social platforms
So, if you got request of me, questions to ask
different things you wanna send my way
be sure to write down in the comments below
or anywhere else in the social sphere.
Thank you again everybody so much for watching
And as always, I will see you
in the next video..
BUBYEEEE